[Music]
in the book you say that that it's you
give advice on how to get men into the
gym men who don't want to go to the gym
how to get them into the gym what's your
advice how do you do it well this is
that this is a global problem at the
moment that many of the women in the
audience I know are aware of like man
boobs there's a horrible epidemic of man
boobs and I keep telling you people are
clutching their man boobs now I'm just
closing my coat yeah so you're talking
about when a man doesn't take care of
himself and gets a little extra in this
area and no one likes that there aren't
fetish clubs for people that love man
boobs like man boobs are like hyenas and
mosquitoes and red ants and sharks they
don't need to exist they're horrible see
so I'm on a one-man campaign to rid the
world of man boobs so the way to get a
man into the gym is to tell him you've
got man boobs and it'll so horrify him
that he will go to the gym well first of
all see I love straight good straight
dudes they don't really care they're
like farting and watching TV they don't
care about their man bugs we need to
make them care and explain to them these
up girls right they are unacceptable am
i right yeah thank you so you need to
what you're saying is you need to
stigmatize men with man boobs traumatize
them and get them into the gym yes we
need to make them feel wretched about
their man boobs also if you tell them
they're at they're serving drinks at the
gym or that there's naked women there
that'll get them there too but yes we do
need to stigmatize man boobs okay very
important issue
you have very stor apologize for
bringing up a fantastic issue and having
a good solution to it I've always said
if I was gonna get plastic surgery I
would I would get the fat sucked out of
these tits
[Music]
[Applause]
I know you're bored you've always said
that but what did you always answer
after you'd always said that to yourself
there's more things on the money list
than that I mean it's in time when time
is longer my wife wants that she can pay
for it your birthday you can buy me and
here's your tit life watch out that's
that's what the bras yeah
[Laughter]